if I were Mark Zuckerberg for a day
first I would buy more hoodies in
different colors the second I would
discuss with my senior team the practice
of EdgeRank as it impacts people's
personal profiles so visa V brands where
brands are getting less organic views so
they have to pay up to promote
hallelujah take them for all you can you
deserve that but I think that it's kind
of dangerous where the Trixie and Biff
if they have a baby or if they graduate
from college and they put up their
graduation picture I think they think
that if they have a thousand followers
all thousand people can see it and from
what I've heard and I don't know if it's
true but if it's true not one thousand
people will see it maybe a hundred
people will see it and I think that if
Trixie and bf start losing confidence
that Facebook is the way to post their
life story to everybody who has
voluntarily followed them that you could
be throwing out the baby with the
bathwater and if enough people think
this way and they stopped using facebook
then you won't be able to charge the
brands for promoting their posts so
again I'm on the outside looking in I
don't know how these algorithms work if
there are any algorithms like that but I
think that's really playing with fire
you